let's talk about the Bachelorette
reunion it's the biggest bachelorette
reunion in bachelor history it's been a
long time back in the mansion what was
that like for you to be with all of
those women again and take that moment
in I just watched the whole thing last
night and I was I was like a
five-year-old at Christmas I really was
I was I was had this weird sense of
pride I guess it's not weird it's my
baby and so and I and I really love
these women and I really liked it at the
end of the day we had all these
bachelorettes together for the first
time we've never done anything like it
so maybe there was this novelty thing to
it where I'm just watching them just be
them and they were having this cocktail
thing where they were just sitting
around talking and telling stories of
motherhood and just being women today
and being bachelorettes and going
through this show and I just like this
is great it's just celebrating these
badass women doing their thing and there
was no producing no nothing it was just
raw them and and then it would then
having them laid out lined up in the
driveway later that night and I like
looking from Trista to Becca and I'm
like wow we did this like this all these
kick-ass women doing their thing and I
know I thought it was pretty cool well
two women were missing yep the fans will
wonder why why weren't they there well
unfortunately yeah Jenna and Meredith
couldn't be there because we had to
settle on a date at the end of the day
we had to shoot this thing and we were
kind of up against it once we decided to
do this and so we just picked a day
where we could get as many as we
possibly could but unfortunately
schedules vacations which was one of
them just couldn't be changed and we had
to pull the trigger and do this thing
and we I was grateful that we had as
many as we as we did which is 12 of the
14 obviously Hannah's not a part of it
she's shooting the show but we've tried
to get all 14 and unfortunately Jenna
and Meredith are represented they're
celebrated in this thing we love them
very much and they're a part of our
family in this sisterhood
[Music]
[Applause]